-I'm hanging out
with Pete Davidson,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-We're about to play a game
we call "Wheel of Opinions."
Here we go.
-♪ Wheel of Opinions ♪
-Okay, I will hit this button,
which activates
the Opinion Topic Generator.
It'll land on a random topic.
Whatever it is, you have to give
your opinion on it.
Ready for this?
-Okay.
-Here we go.
First topic is...
[ Game show music plays ]
Okay.
Would you rather be caught
saying, "I went glamping"
or, "I'm hangry"?
-What's glamping?
[ Laughter ]
-Glamping is -- is -- is --
People say glamping.
It's like glamorous camping,
maybe?
People go like,
"I went glamping."
Yeah, people know it.
-People say that?
-Oh, for God's sakes.
Everybody knows glamping!
Everybody knows
what glamping is!
-That is Jon Stewart
right there!
-Glamping is very popular.
-I'll move over.
-That's Jon Stewart right there!
Jon!
-Hey, Jon.
-Welcome, Jon, to our --
-Hold on.
Let me put my glasses on
so I look like my opinions
are smarter.
-Jon. Thank you, Jon.
You were just streaming the show
from home?
-I'm at work.
-Yes, I'm sorry.
-I'm still at work.
You know, Peter, somebody has to
make a living in this household.
[ Laughter ]
And it's me!
-Jon...
He comes home,
he eats the peanut butter,
he drinks the milk --
he doesn't pay!
[ Laughter ]
-Jon, do you have an opinion
on glamping or hangry?
-Either one of those should --
and again,
I'm not a man that's speaking
for vigilante justice,
but if you were to use any,
I believe it's not improper
to tie you to the back of
a vehicle, maybe a Citi Bike --
-A Citi Bike! [ Laughs ]
-...and drag you through
perhaps Sixth Avenue.
-Yeah.
-Some people call it
the Avenue of Americas.
-Of course they do.
It's very popular.
-And to have townspeople
curse your name
and spit upon you.
-Alright, that's a good opinion.
Jon, while you're here, can we
just maybe get your opinion
on a couple other topics?
Let's try one.
-Jimmy, I was hoping you'd ask.
Here's one opinion
you may not know.
I love Pete Davidson.
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love Jon.
-That's a fact.
-He is such a good guy.
-Oh, I love that.
Alright, how about
any opinion on --
let's see if Pete Davidson
comes up
on the Opinion Topic
Generator.
What?
Swimming with dolphins.
-How nice!
-Yeah, I have an opinion
on that.
Your generator
is full of [bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
What about my generator?
-Your -- Your --
Your topic generator!
-Yeah, why?
Swimming with dolphins --
do you have an opinion on it?
Not the generator.
-Oh, I don't have an opinion
with swimming with them,
but I am pro-blowhole.
That's all I'll say.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ] What's wrong --
What is wrong with you, man?
[ Laughter ]
Uh, Pete, any...?
-I think it's a lovely thing to
do with your family on vacation.
-Okay, yeah. Okay.
You think it's --
That's perfect.
Also pro-blowhole.
-Sure.
This is coming from a guy
who's hangry.
-Yeah, okay.
Our final topic.
Here we go.
The Opinion Topic Generator,
Jon.
-Alright, what do you got?
-Oh.
[ Audience "ohh"s ]
-Mets versus Yankees.
I have a feeling where
you're gonna land, Jon.
Pete, do you have an opinion,
Mets versus Yankees?
-I also root for the Mets
because their fans are sad.
[ Laughter ]
-But as a -- when you're a
New Yorker, you get the choice,
and why -- you pick the Yankees
'cause they win.
-Yeah.
-You know, first of all...
-But I always root for --
-You don't get a choice.
-I always root for the Mets.
It's like, it would be nice
for the Mets or Jets
to win something.
-Yeah.
Jon? Jonathan?
-As a Mets fan
since the 1960s...
-Wow.
-I accept Peter's charity.
[ Laughter ]
And as fans, we win nothing,
but it is not a choice.
My father was born in Brooklyn,
and we were not allowed
to like the Yankees.
It was -- He would rather
you smoke cigarettes
in the street
while drinking whiskey naked --
-Yeah, as a child.
-...as a 7-year-old --
by the way,
not a good father --
[ Laughter ]
-He would rather that.
-...than like the Yankees.
-That's correct.
You are a diehard all the way.
Mets all the way, Jon Stewart.
-I believe that --
-[ Bell dings ]
-...the key phrase there
is "die."
We suck.
-Pete Davidson, Jon Stewart,
everybody!
-Thanks, Jon.
-You can see Pete, Jon,
and other great comedians
this Sunday at "NYC Still Rising
After 20 Years:
A Comedy Celebration."